thanks for coming everybody I'm sure you
all heard there was yet another school
shooting today we have to figure out
what we're going to do as parents
because this whole thing is out of
control we have to ask ourselves why
this is happening and do something else
well you know Sharon I think it it is a
complex issue you know it's it's not
really as simple as just but what I'm
saying is that that with issues like
this sometimes you have to be kind of
crazy what are you talking about do you
understand that our children are being
murdered
read how much closer to home can this
all hit it was at our children's school
crazy time crazy read time I agree with
my wife well there certainly are things
that need changing just yesterday I was
at the park with my son Craig and have
you seen the state of the playground
equipment not only does it seem unsafe
but it's become quite an eyesore the
whole park could use an upgrade if you
ask me that's become a campout for the
homeless I am joking you're gonna take
one second to compare child
murder to park upgrades what is wrong
with everybody
you've all got crazy anybody need a
drink
you